now you just fed me some food truck and
now I have indigestion I don't feel good
Wallace and I got indigestion here's the
thing about one of my favourite food
trucks I forget the name of something
Swami sandwiches no Mather they're
frickin Thai sandwich that I marinate a
steak yeah and then we get also got the
Nashville hot chicken sandwich mmm
those have dope food trucks we're at I
think that yeah I think that might be it
Jim hey guys I'm but Brian goes you know
taste [ __ ] know what what's wrong with
you so you run over there why don't you
leave it on how do you know all right
man well hurry up right back
are you fourteen that's annoying
thank god I've closed all right well
carry on Irwin didn't start the podcast
and then Brian to jet out yeah robot
left my stove on now here's the other
thing that bothered me today about you
is uh hmm I meant with my favorite food
trucks the Swami Swami Salem truck I'm a
food truck I have indigestion looking
truck expert yeah
and I'm ordering a the Thai steak
sandwich was delicious and I told you to
order the natural hot chicken sandwich
yeah any go yeah the muck I don't know
chick muck [ __ ] something like
that or whatever another collected the
mother clucker the mother clucker yeah
and you go yeah I'm gonna get that then
you turn to me and go I need money
yeah you don't you lost your wall I lost
my how hot you know you've left my stove
on 14 left my stove on and somehow lost
more however I think my son don't blame
as a goof don't blame it on he hid it
from ya know and bless Izzy the best
hider in the
world yeah like I put it here yeah I
turned the house upside down didn't find
it so it's either at the boxing gym or -
it's in the box gym and someone stole it
yeah box gym this little box that's it
in my car someone stole up and I or is
it in your car underneath the seat
checked check
turn that car inside out is there
anything more annoying lose your wallet
and you got to get a new license cards -
cards insurance jump up my cocaine
there's nothing else you know I mean the
brats
there's nothing worse dude it's [ __ ]
so for a secret phone sometimes you
leave town tomorrow I think some on town
tomorrow I go to Kansas City tomorrow
how you need out of the play yeah I have
I have a passport right next to me right
into another passport so thank God you
don't be asking me for cash and [ __ ] out
there no I might have to ask you for a
roll that's how I roll the good thing is
I got friends who have money so I'm
gonna go do Rogen's podcast after this
ask him - I could ask Rogan I could go
Joe give me $3,000 correct and here's
what he would do should forget about
what do you mean he just forget about it
maybe like what oh yeah I gave you
$1,000 oh I see what you're saying there
was these really rich Prince's in at
Harrods in London which is Harrods at
London is the most famous shopping
center where you can get the most
expensive things of everything Rodale
here yeah I mean it's like you know and
I guess they had charged somebody like
these princes nine princes of something
like $30,000 for these insane chinchilla
coats okay and they had to of course
tailor those coats or do whatever it was
but the princess forgot about it and
just never claimed those hotels just
gave them $30,000 and just there you
know there are a lot of people with that
kind of problem to have yeah where they
just you know I forgot you know thirty
thousand uh well well stained had five
million dollars or something like Howard
Stern asked me how much money did you
have embezzled because I don't know it
was it like five million good I think it
was something like that ding yeah and it
didn't it didn't even he was like yeah
the guy [ __ ] embezzled but you know I
guess they're trying to get it back but
it wasn't a concern no cause it just
play
one key assumption yeah Dylan 5mil but
it doesn't affect your life it doesn't
you know so interesting you know I mean
uh if you came into my house and stole I
mean obviously my children my dogs but
you know there's nothing in my house
well what could they steal in your house
that you would want yours well you're
not a materialistic do you have some
psyche if like watches like like if a
fire happen your house yeah you just
like um I don't own anything I don't
know any expensive shoes or why don't
you know nice watch yes is that your
style yeah you have you have some you
have some money and some jewelry you may
try and get me robbed or what bro no
come at me now right you're a new
security system what's up bro got dog
security on the guns and I do to watch
over watches over your house so you're
pretty good bro yeah you might not wanna
and then you're there and if you're
there you might get handsy with him you
know what I mean hands the hands you
know I'm saying and we got the panic
room now build out a panic room never
say the time that I heard somebody break
into my house it's so scary and I got my
gun I always have my gun and I rehearse
this cuz I'm a crazy person because I'm
in Venice at the time where I live on a
one-story and there's nothing stopping
somebody from coming into my house so I
got my gun I'm naked I'm naked probably
half a chub cuz I am right it's
nighttime excitement you got to be
chubbed up mmm
and now I'm now somebody's in my [ __ ]
house and I'm going to shoot them well
uh I come around the corner with my gun
and Jimmy Burke my dear friend Jimmy
Burke is standing there and he's just
wanted to get some water
I forgot - Jimmy Burke was staying with
me dude cuz it might have some real in
might cuz in my head - I sleep but
here's the other thing that happened
there was a little minor earthquake so
the minor earthquake woke him up
I woke me up because my she she shoot
and then that he got up and he goes wow
what the [ __ ] was that all right I'll
get some more and I come around with a
gun and I see him and I put the gun down
really quickly how it works so he goes
you have a gun but he doesn't here I go
I've got really embarrassed I was like I
I do why would you embarrassed I don't
know I just I'm just very mad my friend
with a gun right but yeah but you
thought it was a [ __ ]
burglar yeah but uh you know you keep
forgetting [ __ ] and forget your friend
was staying there sometimes I don't know
if I just talk so much by then the day
my brain is just the inner work of my
brains just so fried yeah yes tell my
son something yesterday and the words
that came out were show it was backwards
I got guy backwards Isaac God and him
even I'm at three two rounds like what
the [ __ ] I was like I need a break
yeah but needs a break man yeah I talk
so much and I was doing stand-up that
night and I was just I don't know now
I'm like is it CT or is it I'm just
doing so much and talking so much you
just talk eventually my brains it's like
let's just take a minute yeah well you
you know frequency was when a per I'm a
20-minute nap per after I read that book
why we sleep and that makes such a huge
difference shut it down and then okay
[ __ ] makes a difference man like even
if I don't sleep even I'm lying down it
makes a difference and then they've done
all these Studies on people who live
forever the ten hours all Nappers are
you guys Nappers chin cat I will love a
good nap you're a Napper yeah but on
that on that for like four hours
same how do you smell that would it be
in that yes that would be going to sleep
how do you sleep do you sleep well
during the night sometimes other times I
tend to toss and turn a lot frank grillo
guy who sleeps and I've seen it with my
own eyes five hours a night and then
goes works out for the excellent people
are like so I'm like what the [ __ ] did
his genome and I mean I've never seen it
like it I'm just like how are you you're
out till 12:00 1:00 Slee and just
getting up at 6:00 to go work out like
how the [ __ ] has any it's incredible
never needs in that the doctor just did
his genome the doctor goes you have that
gene you have the sleep change [ __ ]
it's Sunday vanishing some people get
can get achieve wakefulness
at just five hours of sleep they with
their eyes open look up the study though
chin how many people kind of function
off I think it's four hours of five
hours yeah it's so good P Diddy and some
other guys are like oh I only sleep four
hours every was making fun of them but
then some doctor came out was like
actually there's a super rare percentage
of the world I'm gonna get less than
four hours and still fungi Strank the
highest levels Frank I'm not one of
those guys no man I gotta shut it down
and
officer that way but someday my dad
tried doing this study who have just
taken naps throughout the day and not
sleeping at night what's that they found
that lets people get up behind six hours
of sleep I've read about that too though
it's like little naps throughout the day
yeah my dad you know he likes to get so
much done and reads all these books and
has his jobs and so he thought sleeping
was a waste of time so his idea was this
is 20 years ago at least 25 years ago
his idea was just take small naps
throughout the 24 hours of the day so he
could get more work done yeah that's
didn't know that's didn't work
specifically that is four hours that
wait 20 minutes town wait 20 minutes and
I didn't do it didn't do well [ __ ]
that's what you do in wartime so test
failed the test failed Neil Strauss did
that yeah yeah very small what'd he say
about it he said it didn't work for him
but that's what doesn't work for anybody
Navy SEAL and [ __ ] bud I want a kid
he's a guy wrote the game and he solved
some murders and stuff that'd be cool
cool yeah if you give me eight up now
I'm riding off of this if I don't stand
up I'm in bed at 9:00 son and I'm up at
5:30 six of my son you drive hard and
you're a big man and you work out so
your body has to you got to shut it down
like when we're on the road sometimes
we'll be like let's go shut it down for
a sec yeah well shut it down for a good
half hour no more and we're back you
know you got to tell Jay shabd you won't
shut the [ __ ] you know you're happy boy
yeah god damn dude if I see a nice car
coming by Mike welp here we go it'll be
like you know some special edition fry
and as soon as I see Mike let's get
ready for this like oh that's a that's a
365 see the thing is about the 364 is
you know it started in Italy I'm like I
know man he's like yeah so that you know
you get four colors in those he get the
black unis the guards red and then he
get and he just starts right but I don't
I'm not entertaining this conversation
but see what I love him I'm not I'm not
going oh really and what other colors
he's just [ __ ]
he's like a walking Internet what I like
about him though is that everything he
says it's dead-on
fine so if I read something I forget and
I
like I blur shake it off that
[ __ ] is gone now
like he's scientific about it and you
can bet whatever he says is
word-for-word the truth and like if you
get an argument about like about sports
I've never seen you get shut down that
guy's shuts you down yeah he's like oh
you'll happen now fighting no every
other sporting hero and he'll be like
well his eyes go well
yeah but but I mean our family likes
argue oh yeah
your dad Sam way ah really worse so the
3m oh my god oh it's a nightmare
big guys nightmare Oh alphas night
nightmares nobody nightmare it's all of
us in also sensitive yeah yeah officers
Jase aw that's in my dad's super saying
I inherited that sense I had heard that
from my father and had to stop cuz I was
ruining friendships I know and did
because my father would do this so start
making an argument well no Brian because
the reason why flies or we should stop
here for a second because I'm not gonna
I guess I wouldn't romance this argument
in the real world but I will here for
you you started speaking very quickly
and you started with no which is very
interesting to me so we should be a
little more disciplined with our thought
process and if I could shed some light
like he'll do that to you well do in
your life [ __ ] huh and that's
what would happen and then of course I
inherited that you know and I would take
arguments personally like we all did I
know I liked argue but it's exhausting
like when they so when you just don't
just questions everything me and my dad
I'd go hard in the paint and me and my
brother know he's wrong I could be
telling us about a car that we know like
better than anybody and my dad to be
giving us facts about it and they're
just it's just wrong
like it's just not like it's not real
it's literally he's arguing there's not
it's it's just not so no it's like like
you could I can bring up Google and me
like no looked at the option time on
that car does not come and go no yeah
that's not it you look at the wrong one
like oh my god this is from the Porsche
website though this is from portions
like I saw I'm telling you I'll find it
later weird to me but it drives me nuts
man
Jimmy Burke had a girlfriend who just
one day said
she just looks did you mean she goes you
know at the end of the day the big
elephant in the room is your drinking
now Jimmy's not a drinker like he's
rights like me
I think excuse me and she goes you're
you have a drinking problem and you
drink and Jimmy goes I do she goes yes
the big elephant in the room always
together and you get crazy drunk and
that's the biggest problem in our
relationship and he just goes so you are
so you are simply wrong about that
that's okay and she she goes and that
would be a classic alcoholics response
and he goes and so it's your it's your
contention that I'm an alcoholic and she
goes I think it's everybody's attention
she looks at me he goes am I an
alcoholic now you you're my best friend
no man I look for you no way yes I go
you're the worst alcoholic I've ever met
and I told you ink no no Frank I mean
he's like wine got a couple of beers and
yeah he's I guess but nothing finally
just go so you're simply wrong about
that you it simply is not so it's great
I finally I'd be like yeah it's not so I
don't know what you're talking about it
I'm with him every [ __ ] night and she
just had convinced herself but but Rogan
and I what used to be the worst lawyer
we used to have arguments and he was
this way with other people but he and I
a couple times got in a couple arguments
where his old talk yes well now because
I don't do that but his girlfriend was
like holy [ __ ] with no [ __ ] big
al shouting at each other at a dinner
table because we were like 20 31 and now
we were talking about how when we have
an appointed I'll get attached to it we
take that argument we take the idea we
put it on the table and then we kind of
like apply into it well it's just let's
ask some questions and guys are all
older remember where we in Oklahoma me
and Janice came to blow oh yeah yeah
about about the how hard it is to be a
mom Oh John only I was like I was like
maybe like that know you were seeing J
like that you know you were getting in
his face and I think but like we were
kids those very strange I apologized oh
you're such a you say you both are big
but you're you know you are mangu Singh
the old neck I was so upset your neck
had a bent I was so upset your neck had
an extra muscle in the back well he kept
saying he kept saying Bobby them being a
dad's knife yeah and you were you were
craning over and your nostrils were
flaring and you were getting in his face
you know what he tricky triggered things
in me that brought up when we were kids
when we get an argument or whatever it
is yes psycho when I was like what the
[ __ ] I was getting facing what the [ __ ]
are you talking about I'm your brother
Romero's like you his face and he's
really just like oh it triggered our
childhood it gets kids guy that's dark
dude but you guys are so bonded it's
incredible so it doesn't really matter
no matter what that's your [ __ ] ride
or die yeah true I feel that way about
my friends like I don't care really with
my friends I don't care what happens
what do you mean like I don't know what
you do what you could do at the end of
the day to get me we're not any friends
like odd now you'd have to do I don't
know what it would be dude yeah I mean I
you know even then I'd be like pissed
and then I I don't know like if you like
even I don't know I mean I'd be like hey
what would you I guess if you were I
think it gets if you were if you feel
oddness right it might work if you're
Michael Guerin obviously you can't be
friends but if you like if I if my wife
had a child that looked like me and then
you were like and it came out and it was
super muscular with big legs and it was
totally totally in the fashion with a
hairline that came just above his
eyebrows and I would be like Brennan
thinking [ __ ]
anybody likes it look man I'd like your
a day there's one night you're on the
running furious and then I'd be like
yeah kid's gonna be an athlete though
cat have you ever lost any friends or
chin have you over arguments or anything
have you lost steam friends in general
you a lot of friends like high school
and middle school were doing but like
high school even college just kind of
grow apart I moved to LA so you just
grow apart like weird unseasoned anymore
that's just different that one falling
out of my life like with somebody but I
just couldn't anymore if they were just
I just realized they were a cancer so I
just hadn't I hate
killed me it killed me but I was like I
can't I know who they're yeah I told you
you told me from the get-go uh cat not
really I mean I'm pretty chill if you
have an issue with me it's usually on
you I don't get in arguments with
anybody interesting kind of have to be
an [ __ ] yeah I think that quite
manhood with deep friendship have you
ever have you ever had a friend like
cheat on you with a boyfriend or
anything like that I'm not into the same
guys that my friends are usually I like
the nerdy guys a lot of my friends like
the Jockey type you know I did want you
know what I did once but I was in
college and there was a guy was friends
with and I was friends with him you know
and I was friends with his other friend
and he had a girlfriend we're in the
movie theater mm-hmm and he said
something that I lost respect for him I
was like he was he was talking about how
he's in it he only wants to be around
rich people and poor people are not
people he wants to deal with he said
something that I was like God talk about
truth highway like ah Brennan dude
you're a [ __ ] unit I just wanted a
trap drop me the [ __ ] card of you
[ __ ] elitist so he disappeared I was
like I was like it really bothered me
like the way he said it the way he said
I was like that's kind of who you are I
was like oh if things start to make
sense I go how could I like you and then
I was sitting in the movie theater and
his girlfriend who was super hot was
next to me yeah I've never done this in
my life I don't think I've ever told the
story did your finger the movie didn't
nope I [ __ ] had my head leg against
her oh yeah sir pushed like just she
started to deny feedback yep and then I
went I just like Morse code mic pinky
and I started touching her thought this
is my friend who was sitting right next
to her yeah I [ __ ] that guy though and
then she reached out and grabbed my hand
and squeezed it and then as we got hard
with your boner at that it's so hard so
hard I've
never done this but I was like I want
I'm gonna like him I like you so I'm
gonna [ __ ] your girl is that kind of
weird I've never ever done that but
still gonna [ __ ] your girl yeah like me
that's I gotta be willing to fight the
guy that's gonna happen right you know
it's a cowardly yeah but I was like I
was like I'm gonna do a bad thing
and then she as we were leaving the
movie theater she reached max grab my
hand he and then we got down what
happened so then we did so then he was
like all right Brian see you later
Thanks for seeing [ __ ] we got yeah
yeah no no what movie was we got down I
never really seen gone with the wind
with us see you later uh and then did
they go back and he probably [ __ ] her
and then yes weeks later no not weeks
later the next next day how'd it go cuz
no texts or Dean's locked her out in in
apartment in college you said like
having a part of bird know how'd you do
it though how'd she know I called her
okay this is Brian yeah they're in the
movies when you were rubbing my finger
yeah yeah you want to come over yeah it
was uh it was gonna howl and then she
came right over she goes I can't believe
you were doing that I go I know me
neither
[Music]
and it wasn't with him and I go not
really anymore I've decided and it was
my it was like having sex where there
was my I killed the friendship and I am
I also killed that how about this huh
I sure did I sure to the friendship
killed the [ __ ] and it was worth it God
and it was worth Jenny's condom of
course not I had you busting cider I
don't know don't remember how old you
know what for the story sure nineteen ah
dude 20 nothing better and then when I
was 27
she looked like was that little mousy
typer oh this is American College yeah
she was by the memory she was brain
sorry hottest [ __ ] big brain though um
not really
she's an American smart yeah smart but
hot yeah how in fact considered one of
the hotter girls and then who's think
[ __ ] yeah yeah true truly let me just go
by that cuz she was dating your friend
that's both of you sure sure and they're
guys that do that too so sometimes girls
I'm naughty too you know I mean
I'm about equal Jeff the story turns me
off some weirdly should turn you guys do
it in the dorm room I got another one
for you in the dorm room what's that do
in the dorm no I wasn't it wasn't in a
dorm room at the time didn't my
apartment I got another me you're
balling I was that Steve I haven't right
three roommates it was doing it so I
have two roommates I know but still you
gonna be a baller live off-campus we
didn't change we didn't I didn't clean
my dishes we didn't touch the dishes
nobody would do the dishes
when I finally cleared the dishes out I
had sprouts growing out of my drain
sprout that's how it goes in college
yeah then ah New York friend of mine
gave him money for his rent gave him
money for his electric bill
how long does this 1996 [ __ ] long
time ago he's he's a a buddy
I knew his girl friends oh yeah and he
just somehow stopped calling me after I
did that for him like he somebody said
he's jealous or something and I was like
I'm trying to help him
sure I'm trying to help him and I rise
this guy's a dick it made me so mad so
you know [ __ ] his girl hold on damn
Dolan do not over [ __ ] you I'm hanging
out of my apartment on 73rd and between
Columbus and Central Park West I'm just
hanging out looking out my window
Brendon sure I'm looking at my window
probably don't believe it but you care
I'm literally looking at my window just
hey you know I swear on my life what
what happens his girl walks by and I see
this beautiful girl smiling across the
street waving and I go and I go and she
looks at me and I go we got a [ __ ]
Jennifer yeah she comes over and I make
her bagels I remember making our bagel
and I buttered it up oh you daughter
dude how did it go down we're like we're
like here's your bagel yeah do you ever
see Jeff anymore here's my dead that's
what happened really and I and I [ __ ]
her and by the way didn't use a condom
man cuz didn't have one but why would
you of course huh
and by the way I have this to say about
her
she was a freak oh yeah how so yeah well
well she licked your bunny hole
well I she said she said she she said
this after we had sex she said I had a
boyfriend who was Armenian and the
problem was his dick was so big we
couldn't have anal
Chuck please I wanna marry her well I
got bad news is my [ __ ] isn't too big
well I got good news embarrassing oh
yeah good news is my [ __ ] isn't too big
for an fit in there so then you went to
poop down so we went to poop town with
the brown town right there dude
wow you look at you gonna [ __ ] call
me and I'm gonna be busted I gotta kill
the French god this is terrible stories
about me but I'm just your purse it's
the only time I know what your [ __ ]
bro why do you have such a hard at the
end of the day your [ __ ] dude I can
see the top of your dick but yeah you're
my raging boner dude it's not weird
now I know you got a couple stories for
me that make you look bad - no not like
that man I wish I did I haven't [ __ ]
in friends for girls well they were ex
friends I haven't talked to him in a
while so do I say what right now you
better mind your P's and Q's cuz you
friend's little bribry over here you got
any fumble mmm [ __ ] you didn't girl
coming after you girl he's gonna [ __ ]
your girl we've come after your girl God
knows the only time two times that I did
something that I was by the way they had
been broken up already but yeah yeah
you're my friend and you have a girl
even if you broken up I'm not going I'm
not gonna I gotta talk to you yeah Mia
Frye had a text as a k brides Lazaro
come over okay alright what what no it's
not especially after those stories I
example hey you just get in a fight with
me for no reason
ah that is naadi in the movie not a that
was hot that was hot
that was my daddy more at our age do you
man an older dude well there are people
that do that's our governor Gavin Newsom
he banged his best friend's girl you
know that
no no gettin look that up Gavin Newsom
yeah his chief of staff or something
there was mayor and he's hop off that
POA guy I know we talked about on the
[ __ ] current events but
they had those rocks in his ass and the
dude was fist in his ass
sometimes though just think it'd be a
Noddy that would do it yeah so here you
go go back go back now for my a together
for me to get him to speaks out about
their affair while he was Sarah well
she's gorgeous so well you know what
it's all good I don't dumb
I don't do you the thing is about humans
yeah we so she was like the [ __ ] did you
like the [ __ ] yeah yeah look at that
guy he's gonna tuxedo he's a stud he has
silver he's a silver fox his power he
likes to bust nuts he's a stud he's now
our gardener do you know anyone that
doesn't like to bust nuts I mean some
days my energy is low but I still would
do it he acknowledged the affair an
apologize for it look man you said sorry
That's not me - it was his best friend's
girl yeah have you ever heard of when
there's like well I have friends who've
done this one mention names have you
ever had where they go like at a double
date and then the date that they're on
the other cup like couples headed off
and then they're like getting married
staying together it's crazy right
sometimes you're in this situation she
was a 33 year old adult married woman
and mother said I took her I was a
free-thinking person she's good for her
is free thing repeat give me I have
respect for that woman well done
I like you know when you just come clean
we're all flawed it's when you try to
hide when you come clean though the
people there's nothing they can't
dogpile on you cuz they're yeah I did it
I [ __ ] up you're gonna say all right
all right I'll get well well there's
that damn right he said that all right
we're out there's that vegan that woman
who has she was a raw vegan huge
youtuber big influencer on the vegan
movement yeah there's a picture of her
eating fish that [ __ ] [ __ ] hey so
what happened was she was at raw vegan
and she was having major problems
missing her menstrual cycle and odd no
no energy Florida doctors no her doctors
go you need some animal protein eat some
eggs and eat some fish because this
isn't working for you so she did felt
way way better put her health first but
the kind of [ __ ] she got because she was
still
kind of purporting to be uh you know a
vegan but the kind of [ __ ] she got from
people was crazy we were shocked you
guys are so vicious what she represents
you know what she represents so it's
like it's a religion especially when you
go get the community it's a religion uh
whole what was vegan a cube star thirty
reals he exactly it for the first time
months after eating salmon dude what
kind of salmon were usually but I can't
I don't I've never seen a really healthy
looking vegan I really haven't they do
never right never I just don't I would
do it I could easily do some fish eat a
couple eggs I know the fish is a
sentient being [ __ ] off
kind of salmon eaten we're bustin your
[ __ ] genes bro areas looks way better
yeah
seen that football player who went uh
Basie Kido he was jacked
yeah I'm is huge like three hundo Thomas
I've been Joe Thomas really you see yeah
do you see our boy M what's his name why
do I forget his name Jeff no just all
their guess how did Joe Thomas drop all
that weight plane look at the before and
after dude Oh George or Harrison James
Harrison benching 500 pounds no look at
this uh died look at this I think he was
the first first pick in the draft from
Michigan used to be [ __ ] 3,000 pounds
and then now he's a slimming is he
second clamp all well no you can't play
ball at that weight no I'm here yeah no
you can't right no to scan for that yeah
wait to but he was uh he just he would
fast so he wouldn't eat breakfast then
he did no carbs then quit een up six
look at this when I tip for guys to
getting waiting for football when I was
in high school I would take an entire
loaf of bread make it all into PBJ
sandwiches then I'd eat half a sandwich
every hour and wash it down with a glass
of whole milk
guaranteed weight gain correct Wow 4,200
calories to maintain my weight on
inactive days he was huge man back when
I
to practice a long time ago I used to
drink two big glass of HO melt which is
disgusting and a sleeve of inmate Girl
Scout cookies preach before bed just get
enough calories in the day to maintain
the way facts I think the first 25 fell
off in a month and I had to kick my butt
keep going ya know like a swim is the
best form of cardio and keto with
intermittent fasting is gold I can eat
1500 2000 calories a day and feel full
Wow
crazy right look at the change man I
mean he looks amazing
so that's that I would say it's way
worse to have to put on weight like
because I remember it being in college
in high school like having a
force-feeding myself
it's way worse to do that then do
calorie restrictions I think when you
have to eat I don't feel like eating
and then yeah like workout you have to
do that yeah it's awful man hock that's
good yeah way to get rich shakes and
[ __ ] ah so there's a guy who'd these
power lifter guys at a gym where they
build monsters and they were like so
there's some of the strongmen the world
yeah you know what the number one food
they make them do it
steroids yes for sure sir yeah I'm sorry
yeah look but also to gain weight like
what makes you a monster they drink a
shitload of milk oh you know so many
calories and you know what's that what's
in melt sugar sure [ __ ] and fat a
shitload of sugar and fat calories so so
but I feel like so you just do a lot of
protein shakes with a lot of milk and
stuff oh don't worry my nephew who was
eating he was at 265 pounds he's now at
215 but when he's playing football that
was same [ __ ] just a big [ __ ] ah the you
see at al Ward you they always make you
these and they would tell you which guys
had to drink the shakes and then have a
whole shake area just for this by
metrics and it was this [ __ ] the [ __ ]
I swear man the shake was like the size
of a large big gulp and it was thick and
you'd have to put it all everything in
there and down that what oh damn
oh man you have drink I don't know 3/4
of them a day really it's not good no
it's not good it's not good all happy
for anyone yeah but also it's just like
what when warbled it's not good you get
stronger and you just no not really do
you think and I remembered I've been the
nutritionist and I was like gotta flush
sugar in these shakes and like you're
giving us all this these bars there's a
ton of sugar and she goes don't don't
worry about that honey you guys work out
so much you're gonna burn it off like
I'm looking around man somebody's got a
fat like I don't feel great either I
tell ya it's not good well you know I've
tried I've tried very intermittently to
be like I'm gonna gain weight and then I
didn't feel like just eat this and I
talked to body buzzing I can't do it I
just your body touch my body type is
just like hey hey like I'm good man I
can go a long time without food I like
you know what I enjoy intermittent
fasting yeah me too everybody everybody
I've talked to who's like and read about
like the real nutritionists and doctors
were on the cutting edge all of them say
that intermittent fast but this degree
with it but I gotta be honest the most
successful people I know intermittent
fast
yeah so I'm well yeah there's something
that I just and I don't like waking up
eating either I like waking up working
out a cup of coffee then eating in the
afternoon that's what I like to do yep
that's how I feel yeah how about
yesterday I got you know I haven't been
feeling great and so yesterday I had to
do shot the food-truck diary with
kymaro's man shell tomorrow's man and we
did a doughnut food truck but I haven't
eaten all day
in the night that [ __ ] candy like
donut I dude I did not feel got a spiked
urine and I get home and I was a guy I'm
finding a good meal my son's like nope
not on my watch
let's go play basketball so I'm playing
basketball on the Sun and then I was
like shoot a shot and then I could feel
I was getting dizzy yeah I was like oh
my I need to do something oh yeah hey
bring up kymaro whose mom's legs cuz i
he's such a big guy and I was that you
know what he's not he's not thick like
Woodley he's thin and shredded I feel
like the ties you just click on the
juicy profile right there see the one in
all no
the the one which justice the white one
chin the white one white one the only
white one on the page yep he still got
muscular legs just thin legs yeah but
he's a he's a fitter dude is he really
yeah he's not like bulky like Woodley
really he's insane shape yeah he's just
amazing such a stud well-spoken I've got
a superstar written all over me man oh
man I I just I was looking at Darren
till as the next as the new blood and
it's like he's gonna know these guys
yeah till still has oh he's 20 till
knees go to middle wait till it's gonna
be fun yeah and and what and wrestle
just just more experience no I mean he
has a ton of experience you just needs
the you know he's 25 [ __ ] happens yes
here only expects everybody [ __ ] John
Jones right he's fighting a veteran and
Maz Vidal who's fun Tata's bad man he's
won the fight before then he'll be fine
yeah who submits a [ __ ] though
dude how about uh
Deontay Wilder signed with Showtime what
does that mean though well what that
means is you know I thought it was
interesting because you know he's the
face of Showtime Showtime I mean they're
partners built Deontay Wilder vice-versa
he built Showtime and sure although you
could say Floyd Mayweather it's got the
one was the biggest right but you know
they brought down their water and they
put all this marketing behind him and
he's been undefeated under them and
stuff like that
so when I knew you know he was a free
agent that was his last fight in
Showtime with the zone and ESPN it's a
little dicey out there man so you know
showed us he in what sense
it's a sharks market out there sodas oh
stone [ __ ] crazy yeah they're
throwing cash yeah and guys are going
all right [ __ ] it I'll go there probably
won't get the fights I want but I'm
making so much money I don't really care
yeah forget the legacy and then with the
ESPE and it's like alright I'll go here
make it money I don't know if I'll get
the most exposure but I'm making money
the problem is and people go you're such
a homer just hear me out here
the problem is if you sign with the
dishonored ESPN you are controlled by
promote promoters so what's best for the
promoter doesn't mean it's best for
Bryan Callen right what's best for the
promoter Andy Hearn isn't best Francine
Joshua what's best for Bob Arum
for ESPN isn't best for Tyson Fury it's
what's best for the bank account so
you're those promoters can have
different agendas so if you want to
fight the best you have to fight the
underwater fury and Joshu gonna have to
fight each other sometimes that doesn't
line up with the promoters ideal
director so what wild or did they ruin
so listen yeah they ruined they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I don't get me
started
but what Wilder did which is so gangster
to me went okay well what I want to do
which and this is so smart he is a great
people around they're very smart so when
people go dude you turned down a hundred
million dollar deal against his own what
the [ __ ] were you thinking
do you not think he has a crew around
him that are much smarter than all of us
who weighed the pros and cons they've
looked at every angle and here's what
else Deonte goes beyond egos I'm not
signing with promoter I don't want to
promote her all the greats all the
greats made so much more money they bet
on themselves they don't sound with a
promoter Floyd Mayweather Tyson Sugar
Ray all these the main two classic ones
never signed with promoters they did it
themselves they get they became so big
you're to go promote with them so Dee
after Walter went nope I don't want to
promote her I'm a sign with Showtime
when I say sign was Showtime he's only
doing this one fight with Brazil against
Brazil May 17th
I'm sorry May 18th my special coming on
17th don't worry about that so so he's
doing this one fight May 18th against
Brazil right and then after that
showtimes gonna try and fight fury or
Joshua but it's all dictated on Wilder
there's no promoter going right well
let's fight Brazil and then let's fight
this guy over here and then hopefully
can play game over here the deal is he
fights brazil gets past him not probably
starch from the sixth round whatever and
then he can go and make the most money
possible so he can go anywhere he wants
each time he can go there's no nobody
owns him no so we're are we so we'll see
you go on oh my god
so we will see Wilder Joshua we will see
Wilder fury if if because what since
want to have a promoter
ESPN and ozone can play ball with
Showtime cuz
promoters Wow so when people go he's
running from Joshua no he's not running
from Joshua all out of fury
Joshua and Wilder only one guy has
stayed true only one guy has made
possible where you can fight him that's
dr. Wahby yeah he never went with any
other promotion you never had any other
promoter he stayed right where that was
like yeah let's do it
fury than fears like well I'm gonna go
to ESPN well that makes it difficult
that you know by going with them
the roads can be way longer than
fighting these greats with Joshua you
know by staying with the zone the roads
you mean wait up forget anyone else Dan
so what Wilde is doing in what he's
doing is risky because if he loses
Brazil it's all all this is gone so you
gotta appreciate the hustle from Wilder
know what believe I'm not gonna sign
with anyone I'm just gonna Bank on
myself all the greats did it and all the
greats made hundreds of million dollars
good friends he's banking on that good
for him
well we see Crawford arrow spent uh
yachts a yeah I don't know about this
year but but but I'm saying that is a
possibility
sure I dealing with the same [ __ ] Oh
God again yeah they are dealing same
[ __ ] so there's always the [ __ ]
I mean I would love to see that fight
that's you'll see it die what you think
so yeah I feel like that's not last not
next is there any one fight your office
fighting amir khan next well also the
thing about crop after what the response
to my cure to you I do think he's the
best on the planet I Crawford there
right there with them
but Crawford's underside compares
undersized that's his Guzman's his very
big Spence he's gonna convince his dad
now the you know he's the favorite
objects so he's so good man yeah he said
and he lost boxes so freshman dude I
gotta be honest I was like I was nervous
like if Wyler would have went over to
the zone or something kind of it's not
good that's the dark side man I know and
listen I like what the zone does with
Bellator with rise in one championship
whatever they do it I it's just it's not
good man you just want to be good it's
kind of like Deontay Wilder verse
everybody it's a pretty dope it's not
even a Showtime deontic mouthing it's
just a while
and yeah just as a as a entrepreneur as
a fan of his you got appreciate what he
dude what he's risking right now you put
all your money on who if I got a gun to
your head you have to bet all your money
Wilder Joshua I think Wilder beat Joshua
but I think fury beats both of them
really I think furious the best
heavyweight in the world so sir Joshua
why do you think Wilder beats Joshua
because Josh takes hits his his Styles
its styles make fights right just cuz
fury beat Wilder right doesn't mean fury
can be Joshua the same way okay so it's
all about style so I think Joshua lines
up way better with wilder than Wilder
lines up with fury
I think Furies a nightmare for both of
them you do yeah yeah cuz it's cuz outer
who's better than Joshua and fury out
moved Wilder so he's gonna have a field
day a thing with Josh he'd move up you
wouldn't get hit against Joshua really I
just think I think very highly of fury
did isn't Joshua a better sound a more
sound and fundamental boxer than wilder
and Wilder yeah yes yeah doesn't hit
like Wilder look doesn't hit like Wilder
that's the x-factor well the hits like
Teddy Atlas ed and Josh would give it he
said that the old-timers would say a guy
like that hits you so hard if he hits
you in the head your ankle your ankles
fracture that's him
I mean [ __ ] crazy crazy just a super
athlete what about that one Russian guy
he's not he's smaller though you know
that Russian guy alone with Django no no
he's a heavyweight or a Sikh or you know
who I'm talking about [ __ ] bad-ass
Russian guy stud handsome dude
heavyweight yeah he's a [ __ ] killer
um not Povetkin no oh yeah
we can't be relevant Wow he is though
they were talking about him who was they
he's on the top-25 he might be he might
be a cruiserweight my picture is away
might be do small never mind
I brought two screeching halt okay yeah
what can you do man what can you do show
you some good events
sure Quran events let's do some current
of they're just an update on the egg boy
he says that the GoFundMe money that he
ended up receiving that actually
exceeded what he needs for his legal
fees he's gonna donate to the victims of
the church okay I'm good for him it's a
good kid god bless she's really cool
just a little update like that so um
this 22 year old girl from the UK makes
about 12,000 euros a month and her mom
helps her by taking photos of her nude
so she could post it on to seeker and
cigarette naked mm-hmm you like
underwear shots or like topless
depending on what you're willing to pay
for she posts them on Instagram she has
a private Instagram account and in order
for you to follow her you have to pay
$12 a month she has about thousand
followers on there and so she makes
about 12,000 euros damn that's a pretty
good gig it's not a no there's a pay
wall on Instagram like pigs I think you
would like venmo or like pay her paypal
oh and then she approves you yeah and
she proves Wow
look at her she also takes requests so
if you want something that shows us more
you pay a little more and then she said
to you privacy she's making six figures
a year doing this mm-hmm you go there's
a porn star whose mom runs her business
and in fact I met both of them because
they wanted to do a reality show
I'll sitting there with the mom darkness
and the dad was also involved all right
and the guy who was there goes what is
your relationship and I go that's her
mom and she goes very good how did you
know I go and I just had a feeling and I
was like um yeah God you could make some
good money good set up and let's send
you know she's she's all right I bet
there's some smoke shows making real
money out there doing yeah people are
doing that with snapchat right now will
you pay for hot pics
well yeah you would have the same kind
of concept of where you are venmo or
like PayPal them money and then they'll
accept you for their private snapchat
account and so it's like videos of them
do they get a monthly income
that cat porn stars want to do that you
know me white boys are into like a she
can do a dish you don't you probably do
it if anyone's interested you could do
it man can take the pictures you know
he's harmless asked chin because I've
been getting GM's from people who want
photos of my feet yeah I said it's one
painting if you give me photos of your
feet or you set it up we can find
different photos from Google or what
have you
Oh take your fan I speak at yeah but I
feel like that's you know I rinse off
but I'll tell you what I would sell my
feet if you want to take pics on my feet
I'll [ __ ] how much you want to give
me 100 percent would give you show you
my feet why not
I mean I'm not a foot guy but I
appreciate it yeah I have no problem I
mean and then another was now if they
had you doing hustler like poses I'd be
like cat we can't do this just don't do
it please but just can't like you as
your face or body whatever it beat yeah
and you're making a hundred twenty grand
in a year I mean look I'm not gonna get
in the way of money so you would do it
cat or no I mean if there are enough
people willing to pay me money people
are this out star there are women there
are women that wear their underwear all
day out star wear their underwear all
day and they sell them to guys you know
really so such a hole this dude who's
trying to buy my own it's a whole
business I guess pee pee stains in the
front is a service where you call up and
you go this is what I want you to do
this one I want you to wear what the
[ __ ] you take those on where you put
them in that envelope and you send them
to the guy so he can't you make a few
grand a month for sure yeah
there's a lot of that decision you ever
thought of doing that either I'm just
spitballing ideas there me yeah like
whatever you do don't wipe properly no
dude don't take off who don't widen and
run free mile here it is here it is it's
the secret chin Tim you got paid $12 per
person to get in and he's gonna jack off
the chin cam is jacket ah and puen know
for you guys who like a big old age and
taking a dump into a ball this guy has
got shits yeah $12 angles from every day
we got cameras on
but you you could even like there's
girls who make money just people pay to
watch him eat yeah that's good I do that
anyways I just I feel like I'm in the
rough over here with that I can for sure
I don't need the money yeah I save money
all day man
Brendan's good with money well I mean
yeah that just gets insanely fat from my
business idea I'm like this this weeks
it's it's marshmallows that's a ton of
it it's a ton it's marshmallow pie it's
marshmallow - hi I'm Dan I babysat your
band but you're making Bank you got a
bad case of diabetes what you're sick
[ __ ] though I it's so crazy you
started GoFundMe to get into 300 pounds
I guarantee it people would do but
people have that fetishes with women
though that that weird stuff specially
underwear all that [ __ ] feet I'm not a
foot guy but I appreciate a good foot
yeah like I'd notice if your feet are
[ __ ] up but like a whatever it's not a
deal-breaker if you have some hooves
yeah deal-breaker but if it's like you
what it's a cute foot my foot is not
cute no my big toe is so big where
people like dude what the [ __ ] it's it's
the balancer you know that's the first
there there's somebody but somebody
who's into something it's like the guy
who wanted to be slaughtered and eaten
took out an ad said I want to be
slaughtered and eaten and then a guy
suicide I said I will slaughter you I
will slaughter you and I will eat you
and he did did you read that up
that's real they met up and he slaughter
to kill them Jen don't look like don't
act like this is news to you see - like
this one birthday yeah maybe the last
obvious she always has like no huge
boner right now yeah cheers got human
human flesh breath all the toxins all
yeah yeah that was Ryan I mean what
people do those exactly the guy fried up
his genitals and everything else back
there eight-day to stick together oh hey
the guys stick together
victim of cannibal agreed to be eaten
yeah and it was a weird legal case
because it was like well cuz he agreed
to it yeah
and he why he's paying them for this
year old computer expert let's go easy
with an expert stuff whose light burned
late into the night inside the creaking
mansion oh this is Germany it was he
said something I want to do for a long
time dude can you imagine sitting around
your friends and I did I would know I'd
love love to hire someone to murder me
than eat my dick
I'd like oh I can't be friends anymore
huh I mean the screw-up always had the
fantasy I only said the fancy and in the
end I fulfilled it yesterday German
prosecutors crap how mu is had
fantasized about killing and devouring
someone including his classmates from
the age of eight cool since eights the
desired was stronger after the death of
his mother in 1999 of course mo is
advertising the internet for a young
well-built man who wanted to be eaten on
the evening of March 9th the two men
went up to the bedroom of Muse rambling
timbered farmhouse mr. Brown is
swallowed 20 sleeping tablets and a half
bottle of schnapps before me was cut off
brandis's penis with his agreements
fried it for both of them to eat hold up
it said it said the two men went up to
the bedroom rambling timbered farmhouse
miss Wren swallowed 20 sleeping tablets
half a bottle of schnapps before cut off
his penis now [ __ ] bleeding heavily
then took a bath while mu is read a Star
Trek novel in the early hours in the
morning he finished off his victim is
looking him in the neck
little art with hearts kitchen knife
kissing him first a [ __ ] of all time
reading a star but on a Star Trek novel
well the guy's dying you could take your
does take your [ __ ] body and get in
there into the bath I bet the guys like
this yeah Isaac can you just pipe down
for me um yeah I'm gonna Spock and
stabbed him in the neck kissed him first
kissed him first
well I stab him in the neck well you're
asking why well let's start telling now
why did you stab him and eat him um over
the candles and chopped up mr. brands
into pieces with several bits of them in
his freezer
next I take away pizza buried the skull
in his garden
nice few weeks you defrosting cook parts
of
in all living garlic pasta life
eventually consuming 20 kilogram
kilograms 40 something pounds 50 pounds
with every bite by memory grew stronger
from do you like it sick ten bars told
detectives that ball south-african him
with a bottle of South African red wine
good wine there he got out his best
cutlery and decorated his dinner table
with candles he tasted of pork oh that's
crazy unprecedented case has proved
problematic for German lawyers to
discover the count ilysm is not illegal
in Germany well instead they have
charged meetings with murder for the
purposes of sexual pleasure and with
disturbing the peace of the Dead the
accused however has a unique defense
that his victim actually agreed to be
killed Natan the crucial of the cases
issues from videotape made by memories
of the entire evening during which
Brandis apparently makes clear his
consent before singing off in his
one-way journey to Rotenberg Brando set
was outwardly at last a successful
financially secure professional with a
live-in girlfriend cool for the
girlfriends Bettina L told German TV
that she had enjoyed a healthy sex life
with Brandes but they had split up after
he revealed that he also liked men in
fact prosecutors said yesterday Brenna's
was suffering from a severe psychiatric
disorder and a strong desire for
self-destruction
I would imagine after killing Brian as
the German cannibal met five other men
who responded to his the internet advert
what he did not however kill them in
July 2001 a students mm Williams
chatroom and alerted the German
authorities who were arrested in last
December ah he felt lonely and neglected
his child after his father walked out on
the family dude is he like a sexy dr.
Kevorkian these people want to die and
he's gonna do it Wow God eat your dead
he had fantasized about having a blonde
younger brother who he could keep
forever by consuming him well he seems
pretty healthy yeah faces life in prison
kind of got a lock that guy up don't you
well I mean you know this is this is a
very [ __ ] weird this is there are
plenty of serial killers that do this
they kill and eat their victims this is
this is what it is the last stage of
serial killing is when you drink
someone's blood and eat them you want to
consume them it's about power so you
know
[ __ ] out there ladies and
gentlemen yes to lighten it up till a
new answer is a video of a dude watching
a golf tournament oh my god oh I know
it's great I thought you're gonna say
gets hit in the dick with a ball that's
[ __ ] hell dude hey bro you positive
yeah
what is going on here you get a fat hog
well I don't know it's dude look at that
three piece set cheese just hanging on
the ruffle what are you doing James oh
I'm bothered about it - you don't give a
[ __ ]
the girl next time like whatever dude
good friend that's it yes no idea just
looks like a [ __ ] seal hanging over
the Rope yeah doesn't it yeah I used to
do that stuff I put my dick on my [ __ ]
and balls on a plate and put a fork
there and everybody well it was a
journey when I was an engineering
student it's always engineers you know
that submarine guides you know
yeah the engineers in like computer
expertise they're not they're not
they're not they're not into the
humanities that a lot of times human
beings are not they don't really like
them
hmm you know the most terrorists are
actually engineers do you know that
people who resort if I didn't know that
what else we got am so a Barstow High
School teacher was arrested recently for
having a sexual relationship with a 16
year old student okay now we're going to
show you it's the student is a girl and
we're gonna show you what the teacher
looks like all right
so high school teacher was arrested and
they never show the girls sex with a
stick Hannah cuz they're underage no
Neil Fair was taken it'd be Friday
whenever 300 is that Jay Leno how dare
you okay dude can you imagine being that
six year old boy and your boys find out
your [ __ ] girl was a 16 year old girl
now woman was having a sexual
relationship with a 16 year old girl
I mean look things happen this is older
dude she should be the mascot for every
lesbian in the world look at that lady
is she's a dude she looks
a strong prototype for a lesbian woman
she only only wear flannel yeah she she
Wow
he does have the jail how did they find
out teacher was sexually abusing a
six-year-old girl they were doing it
together though needs my read like their
60s you're pretty old at that point
that's legal in some states right or at
least some love those eighteen megiddo
seventeen Vegas things seventeen
different things
I'm sure Mexico hey um how much would we
change our tune if that was an
attractive lesbian teacher yeah I'm like
well good for you right now we're like
oh god [ __ ] that lady so mature
we're so shallow that's how it goes
though you know I know what else you got
alright let's see oh this I don't know
how much this sucks for you but
peloton's being sued for using like
artists music without permission who
damp the greatest like playlist that's
weird it's the best playlist like this
morning I did the country ride Ally and
it was amazing I got these tracks are
great so are they are they're not gonna
have it anymore
they're gonna go through the lawsuit
first but right now I think they just
have to get permission and pay the right
amount of money to use those musics oh
they should be major good amount of
money yes there's being sued for 150
million of course I would assume they
had all the [ __ ] figured out before they
launched it the [ __ ] are they thinking
yeah that's a weird one Richard Branson
I love peloton though man a lot of
celebrities like it I love it it annoys
me how many people sign up using my [ __ ]
and they haven't reached out yet though
that bothers me I mean what well you
know like so many people have bought
pillows on bites cuz I always post about
it and I'm not affiliated with him have
nothing to do with them
and they keep send me whenever someone
signs up and says oh shop you know I saw
Brynn shop was whatever they send me
email girl thanks for the referral
here's $100 to buy merch from our shop I
have 36 hundred dollars in free merch
from them really yeah don't want it man
I'm gonna get down
my air runner assault I'm gonna get the
bike they have that bike that goes like
this
yeah bring that up for a second I see
well no it's just the Aerodyne what do
you like that is you but you use it
right yeah yeah that's really good for
getting in shape you can put it on
different yeah yeah all done yeah so
salt bike Yoda but they're called it
aired on Thea so what spelt I'm gonna do
ah they have to find out how to frickin
pay him I mean it's just a lossy right
now so I'm sure their head out yeah
they'll work it out
what is the thing I they won't have a
business model it so if that means I was
thinking about it and if that means it
goes away it'd be tough man they won't
they have to work it out 150 mil they
could be I'm sure cover the air pods
that technology put on somebody else
right so they they took it and so don't
be a lawsuit but it's good for that
company because oh yeah we're got a deal
and but with music music shady cuz I bet
you some artists like or like not only
be on that platform yeah then they start
seeing money and nowadays are so hard to
make money as an as a musician anyway so
it bothers me though if you're peloton
what worries me is how did you guess not
after write the music before you
launched this thing I mean just some of
them I'm sure there are rights to other
music but there's specific separate you
can tell a lot of the the playlists you
yeah I mean there are some headers dude
hit it some [ __ ] yeah it's great
contestant I wouldn't be surprised if it
was contestant means you can't steal
music don't [ __ ] blast it around
pretend that's yours though yeah but you
can play music if it's a live
performance so if you're a soul cycle
and you're playing different music to do
that so if I do a performance right and
I use any kind of music I want for a
live performance I'm allowed to do that
true no nope used to be
try doing on your special no different
I'm saying if it's a live performance in
other words I mean if people come to see
me it's not being recorded so it's it's
all yeah you can use yeah so so to all
Pelton's record it's so it's live but
then it goes to the of on-demand that is
a big issue yeah cuz because
pelton was great you can do so there on
the East Coast so if there's a class at
4 a.m.
for me in LA I can sway Cup and start
the class remember I want what I seem
playlist right hopefully I figured out
what is it you like about politan just
look great why burn calories I'm done 45
minutes like the music I like the class
stuff you could do it live or
pre-recorded ones a bunch of all yes
last time you rolled jiu-jitsu forever
ago
yeah I can't a rogen at the Comedy Store
their night was like dude you live so
close to John Jacques Machado's man he
goes do come in there with us you just
work on your guard I went I'm gonna stop
you not interested you know really it
was your job I just don't care searches
that wouldn't be fun for you not really
I don't go in their own seat yeah I just
don't want to is that rather it's your
job I'd rather run into hills or
something like that yeah you can go in
there and tap a bunch who is it I don't
know what's up yeah I'm always afraid
somebody's gonna come in and kill us
what's up brother hey sunshine yeah you
doing man what a player how you doing
buddy
yeah what's going on how's the bday dude
you know the good man it wasn't that
good no I'm not ORN you know I'm getting
older I like your how I feel
thanks old are you I'm 38 young it's a
good age buddy safety too
are you really yeah I'm 52 so don't
worry about it Oh 38 sir yours you're
not even in your prime you guys how long
you if it's you're gonna come in there
yeah come on in how long have you gone
over here ladies and gentlemen I've been
52 since January 26 yeah well I use it a
lot
yeah I'm not boxing I'm playing tennis
I'm not playing tennis I'm working out
you know I'm saying I never stopped the
kid never stops I love that I run myself
into the ground get my sleep though yeah
I'll go I'll go seven and a half
sometimes eight sometimes even nine
depending yeah friend of mine said that
you slept one time yeah yeah yeah good
sleep till you look rested I do a
wrestling yesterday oh really yeah
oh thanks dude I think I have a disease
not a disease but like a um infection
like a temporary disease in one of my
eyes you do yeah that one I that we had
died Petra yeah oh you may have a
pinkeye conjunctivitis no no this is
some that little little love Haircutters
awesome that's genetic something yet
from further back genetically it's
really a little bit of [ __ ] have you
been to the doctor no are you afraid to
go I don't like going I like to let let
it just really fester and get to the
point where no you got to live a little
maze you know answers to everything you
have you seem fast and furious do you
know it could be like that but with my
help but one quarter mile at a time so
you look your life how long you been
dealing I got a dive yeah how long has
it been going on with your eye though
your eyes I've been five weeks five
weeks used to have an eyepatch mm-hmm
that might be that might be a little
junk the virus or something okay
whatever it wouldn't last that long
though [ __ ] no that's the thing the
last two and a half weeks have just been
kind of like a kind of like a tent in a
holding pattern
yeah a holding pattern it's business in
a home again they're gonna be in your
eye I'm trying to land in Atlanta
you feel me I have a little bit in the
morning yeah you know it's probably a
bacterial or viral good
do you hear cut uh-huh I'll put this
jacket on and does he look different
what the [ __ ] is happening right now
really different dude open your eyes up
bro maybe I have an eye infection yeah
you do because I'm older man vo
awestruck we're trying to convince Kat
to start put her feet behind a paywall
making Bank of dudes man yeah are you
and just like Asian foot fetish stuff
I'm into it if you do like a lot of
girls do like the put like little gummy
snacks between the toes and people love
that yeah and get them close to the
camera I don't like the girls that won't
put them within like three or four no I
don't like that either now you ever been
with a girl where you saw her feet and
they were just not acceptable or there
was an angle sorry and my friend does
this joke because I was on a roller
coaster and I saw her face from a
certain angle and I was like ah I made a
mistake yeah we do well people's height
I knew what girls got all thumbs down
there in their shoes just like all big
toast
she's got [ __ ] 10 thumbs brothers
[ __ ] good hitchhike it's like a ride
bro but I remember um would you talk
what'd you say well I was getting what I
was gonna say is you guys we're thinking
of ages small feet you ever and I know
you can't watch porno because certain
restrictions with you in your lifestyle
but sometimes the pornos pop on
suggestions yeah sometimes it is just
throw on this little asian girl Jack
that a dude off with her feet half
sleeve mean it'll just throw on you mean
you the controller no bro I keep in
another asian chick Jack's guy off with
you you white guy off with feet big like
cauliflower ears yeah
I've been important forever man give
suggestions oh you are you porn guy were
you I'm pulling off now dude I'm like a
hundred days off I think tomorrow bro
fell you had a problem no parole officer
here I never had I know I don't
important doesn't do it for me I'll do
it once in a blue [ __ ] the rocks cuz
you're into men and you're on the wrong
side not sure I mean what I'm confused
what are you saying yeah what have you
heard tell you what if you heard but how
bad was your problem deal I would just
watch it too much was just a bad habit
like what do you mean watch to might
look like chewing gum but with my dick
in my hand and pornography you know it
was like I was doing it all you know I
was doing it I wasn't doing it you're
like hey like you'd miss [ __ ] he's like
I [ __ ] out a meeting but I was jacking
like that but once you lost it you were
fine yeah yeah I wasn't sitting there
watching after I came any creep that
watches after they've ejaculated a
narrative how's this thing you end yeah
but watch a couple more even up already
ago way but trying to find a lot more
Wow yes that's the thing would you say
trying to find the right one too
impatient nobody you don't have [ __ ] it
I just thought about this car commercial
slow it's hard I'd have to find the
right it was a bad habit for me that's
what happened man what was your thing
though Theo like what was a pornography
but was there a certain genre you were
into um
adult and you know probably yeah kids
chicks with tits and vaginas and butts
you know all the aboard but there was it
would do
there wasn't one certain category like I
thought threesomes you know maybe some
budding you know a little bit of the
dark arts yeah dark arts are fun cuz you
want to see a girl game you look for the
butt action some of the blood action
those scare me because sometimes they
chose some money's butthole and was
still kind of open a little boy hey and
I'm worried that we're gonna catch cold
ain't no I hate that especially in the
winter
yeah it's not safe yeah think about that
dude it's hard enough keep you know
keeping your ears and your nose you know
getting keeping colds out of your body
yeah um what else did
well you're missing that falsely pornos
really come a long way steals our point
Brian doesn't watch much but pornos come
a long ways
what do you mean it's come a long ways
dude I want to hear this so my making
some of his ideas friend dated a porn
star and she she looked up at him when
she was about to suck it is dong huh and
she goes I want you to wreck my face
Jesus he was like okay that's the story
boy is that how why Tito Ortiz beat that
lady was at that story or no yes what
you talking about when he beat up jenna
jameson
oh no I'm talking about out no I didn't
say that and actually kid is a nice man
but I love Tito I don't know where they
came from you say something
no I'm talking about another man change
Williams or whatever that beat that lady
in Las Vegas oh oh you're thinking of
the war machine yeah oh that heat up it
wasn't war machine no Tito it needs an
Iceman war machines in prison for trying
to murder that unity what'd she say that
she was real Christy Mack oh really
really hurt they tried murdering Filner
yeah that's crazy man I would never
punch somebody that's gonna suck my dick
first of all does it make sense does it
I don't think so but I think that um
[ __ ] man I don't think anything
different dude something's up I had
sweats think he's always if you working
out know why not
I'm trying to do I've been having a lot
of backing back and neck pain or back
and neck pain is Vernon with how much of
it as emotional your back and neck pain
good question dude I was just talking
somebody about that I get when I I get
back issues it's emotional yeah my back
seizes up cuz I'm lying about something
you mean your life no I don't lie about
my life I'm pretty good with that but
sometimes look honesty looks dude I'm an
honest guy but sometimes we all lie to
ourselves does they you know whatever it
might be and that's what you're faster
until I don't know but that's a good
question you know I think it's something
at this point my neck in my back is just
constantly well what I was wanting to
work out your push and [ __ ] sleds and
[ __ ] you know what you're doing who told
you to do that I go
dude ancient right like he's on his back
like this kicking the sled oh boy I
don't [ __ ] yeah I'll ride that slow
buddy put a dumbbell on his forehead
like why are you why you little Matt
yourself you're such a talented special
comic your original well it's that's
that's nice you said man it's that fact
it's that's what comes with it's not
nice it's it comes with a very talented
guy you're very special as a stand-up
comic and that's a big deal and rare
[ __ ] air and I know the difference
because I've only done this for 25 years
so this is an intervention I'm saying
yeah you're very special I think see
you've always been you've always told me
that yeah but so always said really
myself alone a little bit yeah leave
yourself alone you give me orders to
heart of myself
we all are buddy I am all the time but I
had recently had to stop doing that
[ __ ] yeah how'd you stop like what
do you I just decided I [ __ ] made the
choice that made I made mistakes but I'm
here and I'm doing pretty well you know
I'm [ __ ] it it got me it took me a
long time to get here but I'm pretty
happy with what I've accomplished and
I'm doing my [ __ ] best and a lot of
times a lot of it was just I just love
doing stand-up and maybe that's the only
time I'm truly happy I don't know maybe
writing and doing stand-up
yeah look what I do for a living I get
to do a [ __ ] podcast with my one of
my closest friends in the world you're
welcome yeah
yeah I make money doing that yeah I feel
blessed y'all you're welcome sighs and
then I and then and I get to be original
and do stand-up and make a difference
just the way you do and look at the look
at the kind of performance we get to do
and we get paid for it don't compare
yourself the other pinky baby do you
know what does it like feel I just feel
everybody hold on out of all the people
we know know anyone who doesn't love you
no one never everybody likes you and you
are an original dude when you do
stand-up all of us [ __ ] everyone stop
thanks man
so leave yourself the [ __ ] alone you
don't know what it's like I'm not a good
person you are a good person celebrate a
little bit from what I don't know I
don't get where that comes from Theo
you're great yeah I don't know I meant I
might steal your talent I'm just talking
about as a person your nicest [ __ ] I
don't know what is you know you mr.
battle no I don't know where that comes
from man I don't know why because you're
sensitive and I feel that well if all of
us feel a little bit like a fraud you
know Anthony Hopkins said after he won
an Oscar he goes he was in our class in
my
acting class I wasn't there that day but
he came to speak I've gotta let say I
was there cuz I wasn't there to be there
my butt for the stars Morgan Freeman but
the story I was there on YouTube I
wasn't there but but you know he said he
goes um I'm always waiting to be found
out as a fraud like I feel like a fraud
like I want an Oscar but I don't really
I don't even work that hard I just go by
instinct and and he doesn't I just feel
like a [ __ ] fraud yeah and so many
artists and people that do things feel
that way hey have you always felt like
this when you got successful no I think
I've always felt like this I don't think
it's ever changed yeah makes me think
about it man you're getting emotional a
little bit I mean it just makes me yeah
I just don't know why I don't know why I
feel that way or sometimes I don't know
why people feel that way you know so it
just makes me sad that people that it
just I don't know
I just I don't know it's very hard man I
I understand it and I feel it and I
gotten through it my whole life
as far as just feeling like a piece of
[ __ ] you know but I just stopped the
other day I was like I'm beating myself
up or [ __ ] I'm doing the best I can
yeah I'm a [ __ ] to an extent yeah and
by the way thank God
yeah but also it's a pain in the ass I
know I'm a pain in the ass and I know
I'm a disappointment to people I don't
know how else to be I don't I try really
hard yeah but I'm done beating myself up
I'll just keep trying to be better but
your [ __ ] life is one continuous
mistake but the bottom line is my friend
at 38 you're one of the best comics in
the world and that isn't objective fact
he agrees with it I agree with it Joe
Rogan agrees with it and everybody else
I know agrees with it and on top of that
we all like you Alex rayon and you're a
great guy so you ain't a bad person if
I'm a bad person stuff I don't get where
that comes from though brother yeah I
don't know why I'm you know even as
bright as he's talking I'm just thinking
about that like I don't know why yeah I
started thinking like well no matter
it's like just that no matter how hard I
work or something it's never going to be
enough to make myself feel like I'm okay
that's how I feel you know what Davidoff
told me he went to a therapist you know
that the end of has always suffered
that's one of my favorite and I'm and
then and with that then I'm getting
tired of working all the time
so it's like it's just like this dirty
ladder kind of it's like no matter how
hard I work if I work harder then I'll
be okay
well you look what are you working for I
don't even know what you think about
that no I don't even well I mean I feel
good about what I do you know I just
want to be I just want to feel okay I
thought just keep being original bro
yeah just keep being keep working for
original self express your same and
that's not filling the hole there well
boy I don't know what it is but I've
started to feel like I'm on this hamster
wheel whatever I have been doing has
been a bit of a hamster wheel that's not
helping and assistance so two
suggestions one is just that dove
Davidoff had said something really
interesting he and I had a little bit of
this a little bit of this in my therapy
that I have been going to yeah and and
the therapist had looked at dove and
said do you feel you ever
it's a crazy question because do you
feel you have a right to exist and he
goes no I guess I don't how about that
Wow
and one of the reasons that I read
philosophy and listen to like
philosophize this that podcast is that
it's really instinct is a lot of really
smart people have thought of these
questions and it gives me some
perspective right it just gives me
perspective I'm not saying the answers
in there but no doesn't sound like
you're just tell me you know it doesn't
know what you know trust me here sighs
back you know what's frustrating for me
I don't know how to help you yeah I was
so frustrated yesterday are you tell you
weren't in the best mood and cat suffers
from some she's an empath yeah and in
cat was like a you know Theo's you know
she cuz I was like man I felt like we're
awesome she's like what you know feel
suffer some same thing I do man I was
like what Zoey well how do I help him
what do i do what I was asking can shake
there's nothing you do man yeah before
you came before Bank came in cat was
like yeah some days I just like I just
locked myself in my room and I don't do
work and yeah just don't feel good and
it's like you know it's just like
sometimes you just get tired of it you
know and it's like you do I don't know
but then also it's like maybe we just
have maybe there's this weird pressure
in the world and in like society and
stuff where it's just like you know that
we're supposed to feel good all the time
and like and that's not the truth and
it's not real and so that's true you
know and then yeah
don't know but no some of that's really
inside super insightful man and you
always speak really insightfully and I
don't think you ever sound like you know
what you're talking about
but you like you do that on purpose a
little bit because you don't you want us
to you know yeah cuz you you get it yeah
you know you get that leg well III like
one of the things I like about history
is that people that are some of the most
influential people how all suffered from
this I mean you know so badly whether it
was Kierkegaard or it was Van Gogh or
Winston Churchill called it the black
dog Wow he would get the black dog and
there's you'd be hard-pressed to find
somebody who's more historically
significant at least in the 20th century
Winston Churchill who read more books
than anybody who knew more and more ins
dog his name [ __ ] wisdom Joe was the
most one of the most brave men in and he
he said he always had he who'd get the
touch of the black dog and that meant he
couldn't get off the [ __ ] couch deep
depression well always had some alcohol
in his system always you've always
suffered from it there I think so
I think so there's different levels to
it all right and this is a touchy
subject because Brody Stevens had the
black dog right yeah sure yeah it's
something and we got off his medication
I think that's when he then you're met
you're just yeah he couldn't he got out
of a crevasse he just couldn't get out
of cuz the guy that dropped him off that
night even said he was fine know that he
was normal dumb [ __ ] so I think for him
he was on and off his medications you
know it's kind of scared you on
medication still yeah I took medications
but I just I think it helps you know I
had that doctor guide Perlmutter in
yesterday you ever seen that guy he
wrote a book right now and he said you
know stuff you eat and stuff can affect
it stuff to start us I thought about
maybe trying to get more like
homeopathic type of ways but I'll stay
on my medication forever until I know
that I can't but yeah maybe it's just
this this thing that you just kind of
have in your pocket and you just it's
always there and sometimes you know it's
there and sometimes you don't you get a
red notice you are always trying to get
better though yeah I respect that
thanks man you know so well you know
you've always you've always said nice
things I remember when I first met you
at the Westwood at the Westwood
Crab House whatever that place yeah I
said start reading man read some books
start with the Bible read forward you
know you know have all the artillery you
need
and then I think you wouldn't met some
hot like I like reading I like reading
the foundational text that gave us this
society we live in because there's a lot
of wisdom in them yeah anything is still
relevant I always like why is this still
relevant why are people still reading
this there's got to be some truth to it
a lot everywhere be an idiot right right
why is the Bible such a relevant
doctrine why Socrates well these
[ __ ] something there's some
wisdom in there that I might be able to
help well you know God gave me a couple
things to read that are that are simple
yeah that'd be cool me I think you'll
like that were my Bible that were my
biggest influences one is the
catastrophe of success by Tennessee
Williams about what what happened to him
when he got famous and how he realized
that that the only thing that matters is
with celebrity dulls your sword and that
the wolf at the door is luxury and money
and a kidney-shaped swimming pool in
Beverly Hills and he wasn't able to
write anymore when the only thing he was
he was an organism built for endurance
and what he did writing those incredible
plays that were the American standard of
art yeah Marlon Brando did and that
changed the world frankly I'm gardening
in his eyes I've changed changed how we
how all of us see movies yeah but then
what's he have famous he lost he lost it
all he [ __ ] couldn't do activity he
was like and he even said he goes living
in this in this suite in Manhattan when
some ancient woman is coming up to clean
up my mess from the night before
that's that's bad for her she's some H a
woman with a pail and cleaning up my
mess and it's bad for me and it might be
worse for me said nobody should ever
have to clean up your own mess your life
should require some effort you should
have to have some effort and then he
goes and the only thing the only way an
artist really like produces great things
is is to be alone for a while with some
good exercise and some rudimentary kind
of things to do but but you you you you
can't create things that are worth
laughing and crying at without some
solitude without that truth and and
that's what it's about and one of the
and well Ralph Waldo Emerson who is the
greatest [ __ ] romantic and and and
influenced I don't know Henry David
Thoreau who influenced Gandhi and Martin
Luther King look who wrote this
incredible essay called
what that you might go speak in Chinese
to him you think your draft pick from
you're talking about Simpson you talk
about NASCAR driver vidacup late for the
Rams send it to you then I'll send it
here I'll send it to you you thought
Martin Luther King you tell them
directions how to get it you thought
right amar Luther King Drive okay Saturn
was a black dude bro can I can I can I
do one thing to you can I read one thing
yeah I want to see what you think of it
Allah grant Martha Graham was it was the
the greatest modern dancer she basically
invented modern dance Martha Graham was
I mean so dance I would see it wouldn't
be the same without Martha Gray okay
right does people see what a letter she
wrote a letter to a friend about about
what it is to be an artist and I want to
read this to you guys because I think
you'll appreciate this it's a short one
she says there is a vitality a life
force a quickening that is translated
through you into action and because
there is only one you and all of time
this expression is unique if you block
it it will never exist through any other
medium and be lost the world will not
have it it is not your business to
determine how good it is nor how
valuable it is nor how it compares with
other expressions is your business to
keep it yours clearly and directly to
keep the channel open you do not even
have to believe in yourself or your work
you have to keep open and aware directly
of the urges that motivate you keep the
channel open no artist is pleased
there is no satisfaction whatever at any
time there is only a queer divine
dissatisfaction a Blessed unrest that
keeps us marching and makes us more
alive than the others I give that to you
guys as artists as people on the way to
try to become original in your
expression never forget that trust
yourself
[ __ ] man I gotta listen to this podcast
more often you and I will have a real
talk we'll go down that rabbit hole and
I can help you Wow give me a lot of
readings my job a lot of reading I'll
read it to you brother it's got as half
the alphabet you don't even see how yeah
you got a spot on the vowels brothers
dude real consonant there thank you
that's the that's right on time man
idle time I know I got a lot of that
stuff for you and I and I and I but
you're an original brother so you
protect yourself
don't [ __ ] with yourself you're you're
too important yeah we're gonna make it
easy you're important yeah take it we
love you may go we need you thank world
nitrogens are the whole world needs you
that's right we love not like I'm
[ __ ] Batman or something that I
didn't know you won't know I did and
this podcast like that what do you think
but I don't know where we'd go from here
yeah thanks Brian yeah both you're
welcome just in general you are [ __ ]
welcome both of you you're waving us off
to put the vacuum yeah well I guess
sun's out that hey by the way I'm
complicated ace I think it's still
number one on iTunes get complicated ace
I keep forgetting to [ __ ] promote it
but I guess it's doing really good your
new album yeah it's doing complicated
eight yeah it's Milwaukee this Friday
Saturday we'll see this Friday Saturday
one show only Friday wants your only
Saturday Turner hall and then next week
I'm in Washington DC shows on Saturday
sold out DC improv Thursday and Friday
tickets still available give them now t
fat K calm Brian tone we're gonna be
City this Friday this Saturday without a
Wallace yeah lost wallet yep yeah Philly
I think we're almost all shows are
almost all totally sold out so we may
add a Thursday show so if you're trying
to get tickets I'm going to add it I
think I'm gonna add a fifth or sixth
show or whatever on Thursday I'm gonna
do two shows Thursday then I got Calgary
the fourth fifth and sixth come see me
at yuk-yuks see you soon
chief at kake.com gonna do you on the
road this week yep I'll be in San Jose I
think it's already sold out but I'll be
in Phoenix next week and I would love
for some people to come out we were all
in Phoenix this
never did how fun was that I was good
do you know the road to by the way
selling out of 38 San Jose improv is not
easy to sell out that's a huge that's a
big room
yeah a great room a lot of it to you
guys man thank you so much for the
opportunity
well you get my building tik calm this
define kid route